[Music]
welcome to the playa de palma one of my
orcas most infamous stretches of beach
here it's party central for tourists
especially German ones I've been here
for three hours and it's incredible
so most Sun summer sands and booze by
the bucketful at the beach
you just forget work and everything and
drink it all the way
you can party with a cool bunch of
people it's cheap but still nice and you
can just go wild not like in Germany but
that could soon be over
since the start of June the police have
not only been keeping their eye on
hawkers and shell men but tourists to
[Music]
the beach is not possible drink glasses
bottle glasses or glasses is not
possible and this is Allah is not
possible ok this is information the next
time is a one report 200 euros in Palma
drinking alcohol in public is taboo now
outside of bars and restaurants with the
new bylaw the mayor York and capital
hopes to impose rules of etiquette at
the beach and in the city a lot of
tourists think that just because they're
not at home they can do what they want
but that's not how it works
after all the beach is there for
everyone not just the tourists the new
rules apply to everyone too aggressive
beggars will be prosecuted
buskers can no longer perform wherever
they like and tourists can't go topless
anywhere but the beach Palma wants to
polish up its image councillor for
tourism
ivar oh ji-hun hopes the new rules will
bring peace and order to his city he
says Palma can do without drunken
tourists who relieve themselves wherever
they please as the city hardly profits
from their presence in Romania for
tourists ah interesting
tourists are now shelling out far less
money here it's again a theater game
that means we've become dated as a
tourist destination
we've spent a long time considering how
to reposition ourselves how to become a
classier place they must believe that
hotel operators on the playa de palma
have more modest aims they live from
budget tourism and know that not
everyone who goes on a cheap holiday
behaves badly on the contrary the hordes
of drunken partiers scare many tourists
away even budget travelers won't come
more due to the terrible conditions the
tough part is not establishing another
kind of tourism here it's making sure
Playa de Panama doesn't lose its
popularity and competition with other
holiday areas completely under one of
the knives but the competition isn't
sleeping either in Magaluf 30 kilometers
from palma it's party time
while playa de palma is popular with
germans Magaluf is a hot spot for Brits
here people are still allowed to drink
at the beach and on the streets local
businessmen predict tourists will turn
their backs on Palma and come to Magaluf
which imposes no rules of etiquette on
its guests if they tried that here
people would take to the streets and
torch city hall 90% of the people here
live from the sale of alcohol the worst
customer is the one who doesn't come at
all that's why everyone's welcome here
we treat them all well back on the playa
de palma people are also fighting back
against the new rules and not just those
who sell sangria by the bucket the local
citizens group thinks the new bylaw goes
too far they say it's just a paper tiger
practice they won't be able to enforce
it fully this bylaw contradicts the
ideals of freedom it boggles the mind
that you can be fined or even arrested
for walking around without a shirt on
any though it mustn't go that far these
rules are dictatorial as mooie
dictatorial a normative ax
and in reality the bylaws aren't being
enforced yet the police are giving out
warnings not fines it's more effective
to inform people first and only later
when police headquarters deems it
necessary will we also press charges so
tourists have a grace period until
hotels tour guides and the police know
the new bylaw but by late summer those
who don't play by the rules may be asked
to pay up